I want to thank everybody for attending
the short webinar today so my name is
Ryan Donnelly product manager for the
gene-editing portfolio within horizon
discovery and I just wanted the topic
for this presentation will be around
tips for a successful gene editing
experiment so this will be anywhere from
folks that have tried to meditate
experiments in their lab maybe they
didn't work out well or for folks that
know they need to bring editing into the
lab but are kind of confused on where to
start
this will go through kind of some key
considerations from for all the steps
across the process and for those of you
unfamiliar with horizon discovery I just
want to take a quick moment to kind of
explain who we are so horizons goal is
really to empower scientists wherever
their gene editing experiments take them
we have a load of different types of
reagents for whatever type of
application whatever downstream analysis
whichever cell type that you're editing
in will likely have a reagent format
that will work for what you're trying to
do so for folks that have listened to
gene editing a bit there's two key
reagents that are necessary you'll need
a caste nine nucleus as well as a guide
RNA for the guide RNA side of things we
have pre-designed knockout guides for
genome-wide coverage for human mouse and
rat genome so if you have a gene within
any of the genomes that you want to
knock out feel free to check those out
they're available in both synthetic as
well as went to viral format and we can
get into that a little bit later of how
you can select one over the other and
then if you're working in organisms
outside of human mouse or rat maybe
you're working in a non standard editing
nucleus or if you need location specific
editing in the case of doing knockin
experiments where you're editing a
specific region within your transcript
to knock in a donor template we have a
design tool that can help with that
so yeah outside of the guides and
you'll need a cast line nuclease so
similar to our guides many different
types of formats available that we can
match up based on the cell type and what
other what guy format that you're using
we can get into a little bit of what
that looks like later on in the
presentation and the nice thing is the
reagents can scale anywhere from an
individual gene even an individual guide
RNA we have multiple designs for each
gene those can scale up to predefined
libraries as large as whole genome
libraries or subsets of genomes and
that's really where I'm going to leave
the product side behind this is not a
product based webinar we really just
want to get these tips and tricks out
there for folks that are starting their
gene editing experiment and one other
thing I'll note is we won't touch on how
CRISPR works there's many many better
webinars out there so I won't attempt to
take that on that's a question
there's many sources where you can find
that but with that we'll jump into
kind of what are these key
considerations that are necessary when
you're planning executing and analyzing
your gene editing experiment so when I
was thinking about this webinar a key
question came up in my mind was how
would we define success of a gene
editing experiment and to me when I
think of that it's that the data that we
generate answers the hypothesis set
forward so if we know if we define
success is that what are some key
metrics that we want to be able to check
off on so we can have success and the
first one that came to mind was we want
the data generated in the required cell
type of interest we're asking questions
around well what would happen if I
knocked out this protein in a primary
immune cell we would want to edit in a
primary immune cell line instead of an
immortalized cancer line which can be
more predictable
um editing and primer Zelda's can be
difficult though so we want we want the
data to be as closely aligned with
hypothesis that we can we want high
quality data so that the analysis is
straightforward on the back end we don't
want to have to screen thousands of
thousands of clones if we can avoid it
sometimes we can't but we want the
analysis on the back end to be as
straightforward as possible and the last
thing that came up was we want our
downstream analysis we want the results
of that to answer that question so if
we're doing a knockout experiment we're
likely going to be looking at phenotypic
change compared to if we're doing a
knock in experiment we may just want to
know the sequence of that edited cell
line
so based on that criteria the way in
which we analyze our cells at the end
will be different so maybe we'll
sequence for knock ins and maybe we'll
look at a phenotypic assay for our knock
out questions and we'll get into a
little more details around around all of
these out of the presentation
progressive but the box that I have here
kind of on halfway down the page is what
we've thought through as what are the
key criterias what are the critical
checkpoints that we pass through when
we're designing a gene editing
experiment to when we actually are
conducting the wet bench experiment and
then when we're analyzing the results
what's necessary for us to have success
and we've broken it out into a few a few
different areas so before our experiment
as we're doing the planning we'll look
at cell line selection the impact of the
mutation of interest how to go about
designing guide RNA and then which
format to select for our reagents so for
our cast nine nucleus as well as our
guide RNA which form out of those makes
the most sense for our cell line and
then we move into doing the experiment
itself doing the reagent delivery
optimization so there's a few different
ways to get our reagents into the cells
let's make sure we're doing that to the
highest efficiency that we can so we can
have high editing efficiency on the back
end and then enriching for edited cells
this can help with allowing for fewer
clones to be followed up with when we
actually do the analysis so we'll walk
through each each of these examples in a
little more detail
so to start the first thing that we'll
want to look at is we want to make sure
we're using a well-characterized sound
line and there's a few different reasons
for that but what the cell line should
look like in principle it should the
first thing is it should have low copy
numbers and the wreath for both knock in
and knock out experiments and the reason
for that is if we have polyploidy within
our cell line it's going to be much more
difficult to get homozygous knock in
clones or homozygous knockouts to really
create a true functional protein knock
out it's just there's more copies of
that gene to edit so if we can get by
with using a diploid line that's likely
where we would want to want to be the
next is the cell and should have well
characterized transfection protocols so
this can help with we need to get our
reagents into the cell to do editing
if we don't do that we're going to have
very poor editing so having cell lines
that have well-characterized protocols
very efficient protocols this can help
with getting those regions in and the
downstream success of high editing
efficiency within ourselves and lastly
we want the cell lines to be very well
annotated we want to know where the
snips are when we go about designing our
guide RNAs because that can actually
have an effect on editing efficiency as
well if we have unknown variants because
just the cell lines poorly annotated and
we design guides
near that region our guys may not sit
down well and edit because of that so
there's a theme emerging here we want
high editing efficiency regardless of
the application and kind of the steps
that will take across along the way
through this webinar we'll make sure
that we're aiming to achieve the highest
level efficiency possible there's a
couple unique characteristics we should
look for within a cell line if we're
going to try to create a clonal line so
grow up from a single cell and we can
imagine if we're trying to grow up from
a single cell that we need cells that
can be grown up from a single cell there
are some cell lines that do not grow up
well if they don't have neighboring
cells to grow up with there are some
ways around them we can do low
concentration kind of plating to where
maybe it's not one cell per well but
maybe a handful and then do sequential
delusions and growing up of those cells
to dilute out the different cells that
exist to eventually get to a clonal line
so there are ways around it but it's not
ideal takes a long time
another way to then to reduce the time
is just have cells they divide rapidly
and that will shorten the clonal
isolation times
the next thing that we'll want to be
aware of is kind of twofold so we need
to know what the type of if we were to
mutate the cell line of interest with
our specific edit what is that going to
do to the cell one and the next how do
we go about designing a functional guide
RNA so first thing if we look at the
desired mutation aspect if we were to
mutate our cell line with the specific
change that we want is that going to
impact the viability of cell growth if
so that will likely lengthen the
downstream analysis times just because
for all of these types of experience I
mean we need to grow up the cells to
analyze them on the back end so just to
be something just be aware and then a
more interesting one is if we were to
target an essential gene so a gene that
if it does not exist the cell dies and
we look to knock it out that likely
won't work well and the reason for that
is if we knock out all the copies of the
functional gene the cell will die so
there won't be anything left to analyze
so likely what will happen is if you try
to do that you can get heterozygous
mutations so you may knock out one copy
of the diploid genome or a couple copies
of apologized genome or you can get a
truncated yet still functional protein
so these are all just things to you know
to keep in the back your mind as you're
setting up the experiment the next thing
to look at will be how do we go about
designing a functional guide RNA
so there's a few things that we should
be cognizant of the first is we want to
design our guides against the most
relevant isoforms so this is important
so we don't get truncated proteins or
different cleavage patterns the next is
goes back to the last slide of we want
to make sure that we're editing in
regions where snips don't exist if at
all possible and the reason for that
again is we want to make sure that our
guide RNA will bind that tightly as
possible to the targeting region if
they're snips there we may not have full
binding and that can have a that can
lower our editing efficiency and then
the last bullet here is we want to make
sure that the guides themselves are
highly specific so while we one guides
to edit our region of interest and we
want them to edit at a very high
efficiency we don't want them to edit
other areas of the genome they may have
high homology such as pseudogenes or
other just other areas that have similar
sequence patterns there's a way that
there's a few ways to do that you can
run specificity checks but it is it's a
critical that we make sure that the
guides are not or not or are limited in
the amount of off target alignments that
they target so when designing guide RNA
is there's a few options there's you can
use online tools to design them yourself
or if you want a company to do it for
you
Brighton does offer pre-designed guides
for knockout so this is the left side
here all you need to do and this is for
human mouse and rat and genome-wide
you'll enter your gene of interest that
you want to knock out and multiple
guides that target that gene will show
up and then you can just select however
many guys that you want to test out for
your experiment and these are available
as
[Applause]
as well as went to viral backbones and
then those can be packaged into
particles if necessary if you're looking
to do knocking work or you're working
with a species outside of human mouths
are rad or you're using a nucleus that's
different than as pyogenes cast nine
which we that is the traditional gene
editing nucleus there are ways around
that too so we have a design tool that
you'll enter in your organism and right
now we can design for 40 different
organisms type in your gene of interest
and then you'll select from the
drop-down menu your nucleates so you may
be able to see in there we have s
pyogenes cast 9 staph aureus cast 9 and
mad 7 those are all preloaded with their
specific Pam's repeat sequences how long
the target needs to be but then there's
an other option there too so if you're
working with editing nuclease that is
not one of these three easily select
other those grayed out boxes will become
white and then you'll just enter in the
specific information for that for that
nucleus so you'll have to enter in the
pam repeat sequence how long targeted
based on that nucleus and then you can
design for that and what ends up
happening when we have the organism the
gene the nuclease will hit next and then
the transcript for that region will show
up what you'll do here is move the
cursor around to where you want it to
edit that gene of interest so this is a
very important for knocking experiments
because we want to edit a specific
region of that transcript so for this
example I move the cursor right after
the start codon and hit enter and then
the guides start showing up the guy
designs that will work with this
specific nucleus it was selected start
showing up and you'll see a couple
different metrics there the first is a
specificity call low medium and high
ideally you want high specificity as we
talked about low off target effects if
we have that
and there's a proximity metric so this
relates to how close will that guide cut
to my ideal cut site so for really knock
out and knock in experiments we
recommend testing multiple guides to see
which one gives you the highest
efficiency for knock in experiments
specifically it's very important to test
out a few guys figure out which one of
those guys gives you the highest level
of editing because when we try to add in
our donor sequence only a portion of the
edited cells will take in that donor so
it's a secondary cut that takes place
well cut the bed worried only a portion
of those edited cells will take in the
donor so it's a percentage of our edited
cells will have that insert so it's very
important to start at the highest level
of editing that we can so that the end
result is we have the most amount of
cells that have that sort of interest
so those are a few ways to design guides
there as we mentioned early in the talk
there's two critical reagents necessary
for Duke for conducting genetic
experiments that first is the guide RNA
which targets our region of interest and
that's where we're going that's what's
going to target where we're going to cut
and then the cast nine nuclease and that
is the piece of Elections do the cutting
so when we're thinking of reagents
unfortunately there's not just one
format that exists so there's a few
questions that we need to ask ourselves
we're doing the planning for our editing
experiment the first is for my specific
cell type what methods can I use to
deliver the reagents there's a few key
ones that we usually look at first being
electroporation so this would be
electrocuting the cells and then then
bringing in those reagents if we're
doing that we're likely going to be
using what's called a ribonucleoprotein
so that's a complex of both a synthetic
guide RNA bound to our cast nine protein
the other option is to do lipid based
transfection many different reagents can
get packaged into there so we can use
synthetic guides and various nucleus oh
we can use protein or mRNA there if we
wanted to do that or the other option is
to do a transduction so we can load up
reagents into viral particles drop the
desirable particles onto ourselves and
use the viral machinery to inject the
sequences into those cells to the
integrated genome it just comes down to
what methods the cells can withstand
there are some cells that do not like to
be electroporated so that leaves using a
lipid based transaction or transducing
in
our reagent so you know that's the first
critical question is what imbalance
without amounts for the cells of
interest and then the second question is
what are the downstream what is the
downstream analysis that we need to do
if we're doing knock in work there are
some formats that we likely would not
use for that example I would say for
knock in we want to edit the cell put
our donor in and then have that be
stable if we were to use something like
went to viral cast nine particles
coupled with went viral single guide
particles what would happen there is
because their viral base we would have
integration of both sequences into the
cellular genome and those would
constantly be being expressed and
editing would be always on so if editing
is always taking place we can edit the
cell
if we're trying to do knocking we would
knock in a donor but then editing would
still take continued to take place in
and around that donor making it very
difficult to analyze downstream so if
we're doing knocking work we're likely
going to be looking at the transient
side of editing to maybe using a protein
or an mRNA or working in a stable cell
line that expresses caste 9 and then
just injecting in our guide RNAs are
synthetic guide RNAs synthetic guide RNA
is eventually do get degraded within
cells and once they are degraded the
editing stops even if we have a stable
caste 9 expressing cell lines because
you need both components necessary to
make the edit so there's a few options
there on the transient side and we've
talked a little bit already about
synthetic guides coupled with protein or
mRNA if you have a cell line that has
caste 9 expression whether it's stable
or inducible you can also use synthetic
guides there and all three of those
options will give you quite a transient
a short-lived editing experiment in
middle though you have an option where
you can have an inducible cast nine cell
line so this is an integrated cast nine
into the cellular genome but it only
gives you cast nine expression when it
is induced
so horizon has an option for this that
the cast nine gives expressed only when
doxycycline is present on top of the
cells so what you can do there is even
if you're adding in even if your cells
you know don't work well with
electroporation and lipid transection is
not working so maybe you have to use
lentiviral you can use a went viral
single guide particle with a led to
viral inducible cell line and not have
to worry about that continuous editing
that it sit compared to if you were
doing both a standard always-on cast
nine lentiviral option with the went
viral single guys so it gives you some
flexibility in when you want expression
versus when you don't so the length of
editing is really dependent on how long
the drug is on the cells so many options
here and it kind of comes down to what
type of cells are we working with and
what is that down stream analysis
so now we've selected our reagents we've
designed our guides all the pre work is
done and now we're going to move to the
bench and actually conduct the
experiments the first thing I would
check is to make sure that our delivery
is optimized you know we talked on the
last slide there's three key methods we
can do to electroporation lipid-based
transfection or viral transduction the I
don't have information on here about
electroporation but if you're doing
electroporation you'll likely have to
test a few different of the protocols to
see which one works the best to get your
reagents in the cell at the highest
likelihood of getting reagents in your
cell the graph that I have on the left
is a lipid based transection and what
you're focusing on there from an
optimization perspective is what is the
cell density and how much re of the
lipid base transfection reagent are you
using so for the graph on the Left we
kept the cell density constant and we
varied our LipPerfection reagent what
you'll see is you get to a point where
the cell viability drops so what ends up
happening is you do increase your
editing efficiency with the more lip oh
sorry liposuction reagent that you use
that makes sense because you get
reagents into the cell but there's a
point of diminishing return where you
can actually have a drop in cell
viability even though you're editing
efficiency is increased so what this
graph shows is once we get up to that
point 1/3 micrograms per well of the
liposuction reagent we start to see a
drop anywhere from like 20 to 25% of
cell viability
so if outcome we probably want to back
off and use the point 0 7 microgram per
well and this will all be cell death
cell dependent so you know just mess
around and see where that see where that
drop takes place
if we're using viral particles though so
we're using it we're transducing our
reagents into the cell there's a few
different things that we need to be
aware of the first is we likely want to
have an FOI of around 0.3 and this means
we'll have the odds of having 0 or 1
copies of that viral payload in each of
the cells we're not going to have
multiple versions of that in each cell
and that's important but the next thing
to look at is we want to make sure that
we're choosing a promoter within that
viral backbone that has a high activity
within our selling of choice there's not
they're not hard and fast rules for this
it comes down to testing different
promoters in the cell line now one of
the most interesting things that I had
run across is the data that we see here
in the middle is from a human human cell
line and what I would think is that a
human promoter would give me the most
expression and in this case we see
similar expression of both a human CMV
as well as mouse ef ef one alpha so this
just proves that we need to test
multiple promoters in our cell lines and
not just assume that just because we're
working in a human line a human promoter
is going to give us the best expression
so what this shows is if we only if we
look at the promoters that give us the
most expression those end up giving us
the highest editing efficiency and that
makes sense the more casts nine
expression that we have in the cell will
likely give us a higher editing
efficiency and that's what we see on the
t71 gel on the right so the highest
editing efficiency of 18% exists in both
the human CMV as well as the mouse ef-1
alpha which are the two leftmost images
that we see there
and the last thing that will likely want
to do on the bench is look at enrichment
so there you know inherently some
limitations depending on the types of
cells that you're working with
maybe there's few good guide RNA designs
that exist within the reason that you're
trying to the region that you're trying
to edit so what are some ways around
this if you don't want to what are some
ways around to enriching these cells so
where we can get our answer at the end
there are a couple that couple primary
ones that we look at one way is just
brute force so you can screen more
clones in order to find that rare
editing event this can be done if you
have automation in your lab you don't
need automation but it'll be you know
more laborious because you're screening
more clones you'll have to start with
start with more cells
it's just inherently more laborious the
second option though is to use a
selection strategy so maybe we have
fluorescently labeled cast 9 sorry a
fluorescent reporter adjacent to our
cast 9 or there's antibiotics selection
that we can make use of and this can
help quite dramatically so the data that
we have here is a lentiviral cast 9 that
has a fluorescent reporter adjacent to
it so with this what this will end up at
what ends up happening here is whatever
selled bring in cast 9 will be
fluorescent and if we compare the
unsorted to even the low concentration
sorted glow facts concentration we see
run a 3 to 4 times editing efficiency so
just by doing this one-step enrichment
you can dramatically reduce the amount
of clones you'll have to sequence on the
background if you're if you have if you
have to sequence them
so there's a few different ways to look
at that and that's a one-step there you
can even take it a step further and if
you're using a length of viral guide
that maybe has antibiotic resistance or
a different flora form you can use a
secondary sort where now you're you've
sorted out the cells that have cast nine
in them and that have your guide RNA in
them so maybe this editing efficiency
increases further or there's just a much
more concentrated pool that you'll have
to do your downstream analysis with so
there's many options here and they can
dramatically have an effect on how much
work you're going to be doing in your
next step of actually doing your
downstream analysis so you now you've
done the experiment the question is how
do we analyze this so I've broken this
graph up into two halves the top half
phenotype the bottom is genotype so that
comes down to what do I need to know and
then the X access really looked at
throughput so on the left low throughput
on the right we have quite high
throughput option so let's start on the
bottom if we're asking a genotype
question so maybe we're knocking in a
tag or we're trying to create a snip we
want to know the genotype of that cell
line so the lowest throughput option we
don't really get great genotype
information we'll get this is the
mismatch detection axis this is like a
t71 assay we use this a lot internally
to spot check for editing efficiency so
you won't really get a specific sequence
information but it's a nice quick check
to see if editing actually took place if
you move a little bit further right
though you move into the sequencing
realm so Sanger sequencing or next-gen
sequencing both of these would be
required to figure out what is that new
sequence that exists in your cell of
interest and for this the decision comes
really would just come down to how many
how many clones do I need a sequence to
push you one way or another Sanger
and sequencing on the phenotype side we
may want to start by looking at a
Western blog now this doesn't give an
actual knockout information but I always
look at this as a leading indicator if
I'm not seeing a band on my Western blog
for that protein of interest there's a
high likelihood but not necessary then
my protein has been knocked out one of
the reasons why it may not show up on a
Western but you may select function is
if you edited a region that your
antibody would bind to and now that
antibody can't bind but the rest of the
protein is functional so it's a good
spot check similar to t71
but it's not going to give you full
functionality information but it's a
good start the next few things we can
look at from a phenotype perspective
would be phenotypic screen seems to be
like drug interaction like what happens
when we hit these cells with a drug of
interest this can range anywhere from
low throughput to very high throughput
depending on how these are arrayed out
how many wells are present and then on
the other a little bit higher
potentially higher throughput looking at
fact sorting so one of the things you
can think of here is if say you're
targeting a cell surface receptor on a
[Music]
yeah on a cell and you want to knock
that out you can have a fluorescent
antibody that would traditionally binds
that solar cell surface receptor but if
you knock out that protein that gives
you this receptor your buck antibody
won't bind so you can do a negative sort
with fact sorting to pull out those
cells that have had the knockout occur
so this once again this just comes down
to what was my initial question that I
had when I set out to do the editing
experiment and marrying that with the
technique that's going to give me that
answer
and that really brings us to the end of
kind of the editing workflow and all the
considerations that we should be aware
of when we're setting out to do editing
experiments if you still have questions
you know I point and really recommend
anybody on the call to check out
horizons website we have really great
information on selection guides for
reagents so if you want a little more
insight into when you would select one
format over the other please there's
great work there that can help guide you
with that and then once that selections
been made that we have workflow diagrams
for each reagent category so step by
step what is necessary if I use a
synthetic guide coupled with mRNA or
synthetic guide bound to protein versus
using an inducible cast nine line or
even lentiviral option so step-by-step
guides regardless of the reagent format
and then we have application notes so
there's been we get a lot of questions
around editing and primary cells so how
would you go about doing this in IPS C's
T cells or doing in vivo work we have
some application notes and posters that
can give guidance around there if you're
doing a knockin experiments there's some
a few other considerations that I didn't
get into a lot of detail and with this
presentation things around how do you go
about designing that donor what formats
is should the donor take should should
that donor be and things like that and
we have additionally some posters and
application notes that can give guidance
for knocking experiment and throughout
the process if there's questions that
you just need a little more help with we
have a really great technical support
team there they're specific to our
CRISPR portfolio available by phone and
chat or email whichever is easier
they're there to help so you know at the
end of the day I hope this presentation
was beneficial for those of you
regardless of where you are in the
process if you're just thinking about
bringing gene editing in or if you've
done it already
I just want to hope that it's going to
give some background on the step you
know step by step what things should we
be thinking about as we're planning
conducting and
living our data 14 na experiments and
with that I just want to thank everybody
for listening